hey everyone this is a companion piece
to my Castle Rock series where I analyze
the teaser for the upcoming episode so
if you don't want to be spoiled click
away and if you haven't seen it yet
check out my link in the description
below and make sure to come back episode
eight is called past perfect and the
first shot is of Gordon who he met as
the new owner of Dale Lacey's home in
episode 4 his wife looks on in shock and
you can make out what looks like a
painting of the kid in the background
which would corroborate my theory that
there are paintings in that locked
portion of the Lacey home a new cop
character we haven't seen yet tells
Henry maybe he'll think twice before
springing a lunatic from prison she's a
fairly well-known actress so we may see
her for the next few episodes we then
see Wendell watching a body being taken
away like Lee Allen Pangborn who he saw
shot in the last episode he or Henry
looks at more pictures of the kid
this one looks eerily similar to what he
saw in the anechoic chamber
this is Lacey's former home and it looks
like Gordon has covered the entirety of
it in these paintings super creepy young
Henry here's the skismo while the kid
asks do you hear it finally likely
referring to adult Henry finally being
able to hear it Gordon whacks a dude in
the face with a book perhaps this
incident is what got him fired from his
university professor job a gun gets
pulled on Henry and Gordon attacks what
seems to be Henry the teaser ends with
the kid being reunited with Molly and
her asking him what are you doing here
this likely occurring the night of the
Pangborn incident this looks like a
crazy episode where we delve a little
more into Gordon and the secrets Dale
Lacey has been hiding I hope you'll
subscribe for my full breakdown on
episode 8 coming out this Thursday see
you then